what's up guys we're nikon's experience
store here in singapore and we have just
experienced the all-new z30 of course
there's some videos out today it's just
launched and we've got our first hands
on it and first impressions it's a very
impressive camera very similar to the
zfc the z50 of course but there is no
evf or any sort of viewfinder using the
display in the back of it because it is
designed primarily for videographers and
for bloggers out there for video content
of course it does take photos as well
but it is designed for video first and
foremost the same 20 megapixel aps-c
sensor that we're seeing in the zfc and
the z50 is carried over into this camera
as well but you got 4k 30 no crop 4k 30
and you can do continuous recordings 125
minutes about two hours and five minutes
thereabouts very similar to the z9 in
that regard you can do 1080 at 120 as
well so um this is an impressive little
video camera out there for a lot of you
out there that would do content creation
you're doing youtube like this right
here and you're going hey wait a second
i need something small easy compact
lightweight i can flip out the display
now you don't have that odd uh flip down
display like you have on the z50 you've
got the normal display like this this is
gonna be a camera that you may want to
consider now of course
in the uh competition out there i think
the closest would be the sony zve10 but
what the nice thing is that we're seeing
here is i feel that the body the design
the grip
is really designed to be used a lot more
easier than probably the zve 10 in that
regard the zv10 seems like a compact
camera that's aps-c but this has got a
fantastic grip great buttons function
buttons all over the place a large
record button on the top of this as well
so this makes it very easy to record
then you got uh two microphones here you
got the cats right here that's kind of
synced up here with this it's a kind of
a clip from small rig that they
partnered with that you can slide this
on to give you those uh those dead cats
right here on the top of it to uh reduce
the mic sound or remove the outside
interference from the mics then of
course there is a bluetooth grip from
small rake that nikon's worked with them
as well with this so you can control the
camera so if you want to go full
vlogging mode like this walking around
you can do so so what i'm going to do
right now is i've actually got the 16 to
50 3.5 to 6.3 dx lens i'm gonna do a
quick vlogging sample for you guys to
see what it's like how it sounds with
the internal mics on the camera then
i'll come back with some more footage of
my final thoughts
all right guys we're doing a bit of a
vlogging test here with the nikon z30
there's exactly there with the z62 there
he is right there eye tracking is
enabled on this it's on aff mode logs on
eye tracking sticks like blue of course
you got the small rig
grip here which has the arrows and then
i can adjust how would i want you know
in focus but i'm letting it do its thing
right now we're going to walk around
this and see how it
performs you're actually hearing the
audio from the camera right now to get
an idea of how it sounds we've got the
dead cats on it but yeah so far so good
exposure's really good on this we're
doing 4k 30 full frame
and uh yeah no crop we're using the 16
to 50 lens
and yeah this is a great lens for
vlogging
got some pretty good depth of field
zacky what's up there you are there you
are is this move when you walk i can't
uh
i can't walk that far it's kind of
crowded here
it's a bit tough to
have to walk around here you know
it's like i could take three steps and
then we stopped so you know hard to tell
image stabilization yeah
there we go now we can walk more let's
walk more i walk to you okay we'll see
how the steps go
actually it's pretty stable yeah it's
stable your hand is the gimbal my hand
is the gimbal
that's actually really good
image quality is great
eye tracking sticks really it sticks
good man really good
okay
then of course i can set it down let's
say i'm doing some uh i want to do flu
vlog vlogging you know what i mean
let's try that
let's do this let's set this down all
right
let's say i want to
adjust here and i want to do some
vlogging let's say i want to show off
the all-new 800 millimeter
f6.3 pf lens right pf
and this is actually very small
for 800. i'm just doing a whole
video right now with 800.
look at this lens look at how small this
is
we all small in 800 millimeter lenses
honestly exactly is this small or what
this is small right i'm actually doing a
vlogging session now with this whole
thing
then we got the 400 2.8 with the
teleconverter built onto it that's a
badass lens
yes indeed
that is the big daddy right here you
guys want to see what i'm talking about
because i'm doing a vlogging session
okay this is heavier
this is the 400 with the teleconverter
on this damn man
this is sick
i love this
wow
this is so good this is really good you
see where that focuses
like when you bring the width yeah yeah
it does nice
right
yeah it's focused
it's working
tracking's great this feels so good
zacky
i love big lenses
i'm sure you do that sounds wrong but i
like big lenses i really do
but um
yeah there we go it's a bit of a
vlogging setup here so if you want to do
some of that stuff then of course with
the grip
pick it back up again
and i'm off and going
let's see how it works here
group selfie
so as we saw from the video footage not
bad at all actually it's actually pretty
impressive now this is the same 20
megapixel uh aps-c sensor as i mentioned
earlier from the zfc the z50 it's now
brought into the z30 so in terms of
image quality if you want to just take
stills with this you can do that now you
do not have an evf on top of this or any
sort of viewfinder so you are reliant on
the rear display but the image quality
is very much exactly the same as you're
gonna get out of the zfc no issues at
all with that great colors great
performance auto focusing is there but i
think this camera is geared more towards
video whereas the zfc the z50 that's
more towards photography that also do
video so that's where the z30 sort of
comes into play as video centric first
no evf on top of it so kind of more for
videographers out there then those other
cameras if you're more distills you can
look in that direction but you can still
take great photos with this no issues at
all but i do like the fact that we do
now do have this flip out display the
z50 was a more of a odd kind of
downwards thing which if you were using
a grip like this you couldn't utilize
the display this
flips out to the side and you can rotate
it as well and also i really uh talk
about a feature that we noticed as well
there's a selfie mode so you could turn
this on and off inside the camera so
when you want to go selfie mode and you
want to flip out this display less
information will show up
as you would see from the rear it kind
of turns it off so you could see more of
your image that you want
without all the distractions of let's
say audio levels or you know various
different modes that are on the camera
you can turn this on or off depending on
how you wanted to do now we turned it
off for vlogging because we want to see
how the audio recording is for the mics
but you can have it up to you just want
something simple and easy so something
to take note of there um
outside of that though we haven't really
played with the grip that much but i
mean
i mean small rig and nikon have worked
with each other works relatively well
the buttons controls are there so once
you sync it up should be no issues at
all with that and yeah i mean i love the
grip on this it's absolutely solid it
feels great i mean it's a lightweight
camera but this feels very very robust
there is one thing i do want to point
out though we have a mic input we have
an hdmi input and we have a usbc input
now the hdmi is a micro hdmi but there
is no headphone jack inside of this
camera system that's something to keep
in mind but again you have your audio
levels here but it is something that you
rely on i don't know if that may or be
or may or not be a deal breaker but it
is something to consider there is no my
uh headphone jack inside of this camera
one uhs2 card slot that is at the bottom
by the battery here um like the other
you know aps-c camera system so you know
again for a camera like this one card
slot is gonna be more than enough and
again it's just two hours and five
minutes of recording so
you're gonna be fine i don't think
you're gonna be uh swapping out cards
and that's you know you get a larger
capacity card
you'll be fine anyway those are my first
impressions on the z30 we'll come back
with a full review in the near future uh
if you like this video hit that like
button subscribe button and also that
notification bell we got a lot more
great content coming your way here on
geek culture from movie reviews camera
reviews uh gaming stuff a lot of stuff
on the channel dude do check out the
videos with that take care stay safe and
we will chat to you soon bye
you